[Musik]
dringender appell der bundeskanzlerin
jeder muss in der korona krise
verantwortung übernehmen und besonders
gefährdete schützen
die zahl der infizierten in deutschland
ist wieder stark gestiegen auf fast 1600
menschen
krankenhausärzte schlagen alarm
italiens gesundheitssystem gerät wegen
tausender corona intensivpatienten an
seine grenzen weitere wichtige vor
wahlen gehen haben joe biden der frühere
us-vizepräsident könnte schon bald
präsidentschaftskandidat der demokraten
werden
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers meine damen und herren
guten abend hinein heute um 7 danke dass
sie bei uns sind sport nachher in der
sendung mit kristin otto sehr gerne
schön programmen der korona virus
ausbruch ist jetzt offiziell eine
pandemie also eine infektion die sich
weltweit unbegrenzt ausbreitet das ist
seit heute abend die einstufung der
weltgesundheitsorganisation
deren chef hat drei wichtige punkte
genannt die whu sei gleichermaßen tief
besorgt einerseits über das tempo der
ausbreitung und die schwere der
erkrankungen aber andererseits auch über
das alarmierende niveau der untätigkeit
tross atomgipfel jesus sagte die zahl
der fälle außerhalb chinas sei in zwei
wochen um das 13 fache angestiegen was
kommt auf deutschland zu wie sollen sich
die deutschen verhalten im kampf gegen
das corona virus heute hat sich dazu die
bundeskanzlerin zu wort gemeldet und an
unsere solidarität füreinander
appelliert die bundesregierung will zeit
gewinnen mit blick auf das tempo mit dem
sich das virus ausbreitet wir beginnen
unsere berichterstattung heute abend mit
patricia wiedemeier in berlin
es ist die dritte große krise ihrer
amtszeit nach banken und
flüchtlingskrise nun also corona und die
kanzlerin versucht wie auch in den
jahren zuvor
ruhe und gelassenheit auszustrahlen
mahnt die gesellschaft zum zusammenhalt
da sind unsere solidarität unsere
vernunft unser herz füreinander schon
auf eine probe gestellt von der ich mir
wünsche dass wir diese probe auch
besteht keine panik auslösen aber auch
nichts verharmlosen die kanzlerin
verspricht alles zu tun was nötig sei
von einer milliarde mehr für das
gesundheitssystem ist die rede
offen ist ob die schwarze null haltbar
ist noch kann sich die lage täglich
verändern
weiter muss man verstehen wenn das virus
da ist und noch keine immunität der
bevölkerung gegenüber diesen virus
vorliegt keine impfmöglichkeiten
existieren auch noch keine
therapiemöglichkeiten dass dann ein
hoher prozentsatz experten sagen 60 bis
70 prozent der bevölkerung
infiziert werden so lange dieser zustand
so bleibt jetzt gehe es vor allem darum
eine rasche ausweitung zu verhindern die
absage von großveranstaltungen fußball
spiele ohne fans das sei richtig
der gesundheitsminister mahnt dass sich
auch jüngere die ein eher geringeres
risiko haben solidarisch zeigen sollen
könnte ja jemand jüngeres denken wir gar
nicht betroffen was habe ich denn damit
zu tun kann einfach weiter machen wie
bisher
und ich finde wichtig dass wir das in
die gesellschaft in die familien tragen
müssen dass es hier um den schutz der
anderen geht innerhalb der familie um
die eltern die großeltern und innerhalb
der gesellschaft dass wir alle auf ein
stück alltag verzichten
konkrete vorgaben können weder kanzlerin
noch minister machen in einem föderalen
staat entscheidet jeder für sich aber
merkels botschaft ist klar
föderalismus ist nicht dafür da dass man
verantwortung wegschieben sondern
föderalismus ist dafür da dass jeder an
seiner stelle verantwortung wahrnimmt
morgen trifft sich die kanzlerin mit den
ministerpräsidenten vielleicht gibt es
ja dann endlich ein einheitliches
vorgehen aller bundesländer
solange insgesamt gleich erstmal noch
mal zur angela merkel heute chakuza
banerjee hat das in berlin beobachtet
für uns dynamik und das war ja ein
anderer ansatz schon von ort und art des
auftritts als wir ihnen bei den
europäischen amtskollegen der
bundeskanzlerin gesehen haben die treten
vier folgt mit einer ganzen reihe von
restriktionen die sie da verhängen
was ist denn die strategie der
bundeskanzlerin ja wenn man sich die
kulisse anschaut dann wirkt das ganze
natürlich relativ nüchtern aber wenn man
weiß dass angela merkel in der letzten
zeit eigentlich fast gar nicht mehr zur
eigenen themen vor die presse gegangen
ist dann ist das heute fast schon ein
paukenschlag gewesen in berlin dass sie
vor die presse gegangen ist sondern
zeichen dafür wie ernst die
bundesregierung auch diese lage hier
nimmt sie hat interessanterweise das
ganze in dieser pressekonferenz nicht
zur chefsache gemacht das kann sie auch
nicht so sehr wie ihr zb französischer
amtskollege der kann er durch regieren
als sie da ist das deutsche system so
nicht für geschaffen
sie hat sich aber im prinzip der
ortschef vermittlerin gemacht und hat
erst einmal erklärt wo wer wofür
zuständig ist die wissenschaft für die
analyse und die empfehlungen ihre
fachminister dafür um der wirtschaft
unter die arme zu greifen
und das gesundheitssystem weiter am
laufen zu halten und jeder einzelne eben
dafür dass sich die epidemie möglichst
langsam verbreitet für sich selbst hat
sie darauf hingewiesen dass sie eben
morgen die ministerpräsidenten trifft am
freitag noch einmal mit
arbeitgebervertretern und den
gewerkschaften redet also das ganze
könnte man so unter das motto stellen
die strategie heißt den ernst der lage
zu benennen aber trotzdem irgendwie
verlässlichkeit auszustrahlen
trotzdem muss man sagen sie hat in der
pressekonferenz auch klar gemacht dass
das ganze grenzen hat man könne nicht
mit absoluter sicherheit sagen wie sich
diese epidemie entwickelt das heißt die
bundesregierung wird in den nächsten
wochen immer wieder die strategie
überprüfen müssen und anpassen müssen
und es ist gut möglich dass angela
merkel auch wenn sie das ganze nicht zur
chefsache machen will in der nächsten
zeit noch häufiger vor die presse treten
muss ich sagte dankeschön gucken wir auf
die situation inzwischen zählt das
robert koch institut in deutschland 1567
infizierte
das sind fast 400 mehr als gestern der
kreis heinsberg meldet den bundesweit
dritten todesfall auch das elsass und
lothringen in frankreich gelten jetzt
offiziell als risikogebiete erstmals
also eine region die direkt an
deutschland grenzt an unis und
hochschulen in baden-württemberg bayern
und berlin wird das sommersemester erst
nach ostern beginnen und im fußball
läuft gerade das erste spiel in der
bundesliga geschichte vor leeren rängen
gladbach gegen köln florian golczyk
berichtet geister vor dem geisterspiel
verkleidung aus protest eigentlich wären
mehr als 50.000 zum rheinischen derby
gekommen jetzt sind es nur ein paar
weniger und auch die müssen draußen
bleiben
begeistert sind sie darf und nicht
extrem schade dass wird jemand schafft
nicht im stadion unterstützen können und
das spiel auch nicht dann hautnah
erleben können
köln gegen gladbach ohne fans geht
absolut gar nicht findet annemarie
fußball spiele ohne fans abgesagte
messen und konzerte
und trotzdem bleibt der umgang mit
großereignissen uneinheitlich denn viele
privat organisierte veranstaltungen
finden weiter statt
berlins regierender oberbürgermeister
fordert klare richtlinien für die länder
vom bund
ich würde mich auch freuen denn
ersparnis nicht nur bei empfehlungen
lässt sondern empfehlungen auch versucht
so durchsetzungsstark umzusetzen dass
sie für uns in den ländern und kommunen
tatsächlich auch eine richtschnur sind
an denen wir uns orientieren können
gefragt ist aber auch jeder einzelne so
appelliert auch heute wieder der chef
des robert koch instituts vor allem um
ältere und chronisch kranke in der
gesellschaft zu schützen
man kann sie natürlich am leichtesten
dadurch schützen dass man ihnen eben
keine infektionsgefahr aussetzt und wir
erarbeiten gerade auch mit kolleginnen
kollegen aus dem ausland bestimmte
empfehlungen wie wir diese gruppe
besonders schützen können um die
ausbreitung zumindest zu verlangsamen
bleiben auch in immer mehr bundesländern
hochschulen vorerst zu wie er in
stuttgart soll das sommersemester nun
erst nach ostern starten die nachrichten
aus italien lassen besonders aufhorchen
und sind anlass für gesundheitsbehörden
auch bei uns ganz deutlich klar zu
machen dass auch wir uns jetzt
vorbereiten müssen
italien ist das von kona virus am
schwersten betroffene land in europa 827
todesfälle mehr als 12.000 infizierte
was das für die situation in den
krankenhäusern heiß zeigen immer mehr
alarmierende berichte von ärzten dort
corona kam wie ein tsunami über uns
sagen sie besonders in norditalien ist
die lage auf den intensivstationen
dramatisch viele mediziner und
krankenschwestern am ende ihrer kräfte
andreas postel berichtet
krankenhausbetten und intensivstationen
voll belegt und besonders aus der
lombardei berichte von ärzten im
dauereinsatz wie hier aus dem hospital
sakko in mailand zum glück haben wir
noch keinen infizierten arzt oder
pfleger hier
wir arbeiten alle zwölf stunden am tag
um unsere patienten zu versorgen
die medizinische versorgung teilweise am
limit wegen der starken zunahme von
patienten hat sich eine reihe
renommierter mediziner des landes in
einem brandbrief an die regierung in rom
gewandt wir glauben nicht dass es uns
gelingen wird genügend strukturen geräte
ärzte und krankenschwestern zu haben um
eine so hohe zahl von kranken behandeln
zu können
in der lombardei wird der ruf nach noch
härteren sanktionen laut schließung
aller geschäfte und büros eine
gratwanderung zwischen gesundheitsschutz
und ökonomie wirtschaftlich bedeutet das
für uns ein drama aber wir müssen dieses
opfer bringen um wirtschaft und
gesundheitssystem zu stärken hat das
hoch verschuldete italien heute ein
milliardenschweres hilfspaket auf den
weg gebracht
wir haben eine außerordentliche summe
von 25 milliarden euro genehmigt wir
sind uns der schwierigkeiten bewusst mit
denen das land in dieser notlage
konfrontiert ist wegen der korona virus
epidemie wird italien das
haushaltsdefizit in diesem jahr um 20
milliarden euro erhöhen
es gibt viele wichtige nachrichten rund
um das virus und immer noch viele offene
fragen auf heute de und in der heute app
jederzeit zum nachlesen finden sie
unseren live blog mit allen
entwicklungen und mit den aktuellen
zahlen so viel im moment dazu wer tritt
an gegen donald trump im kampf um das
weiße haus im duell der demokraten joe
biden und bernie sanders sieht es nach
den bisherigen vorwahlen ziemlich
eindeutig aus gestern wurde in sechs
weiteren bundesstaaten gewählt dabei hat
joe biden ordentlich abgeräumt er kommt
nach jetzigem stand auf insgesamt 857
delegiertenstimmen
sein gegner bernie sanders auf 709 damit
hat beiden beste chancen auf dem
parteitag der demokraten gewählt zu
werden
katerstimmung bei bernie sanders
nach seiner niederlage am sogenannten
kleinen super dienstag hüllt er sich
erst einmal in schweigen von sechs
bundesstaaten konnte er nur einen klar
gewinnen gibt er auf oder bleibt er im
rennen bei der pressekonferenz vor gut
einer stunde gibt er an
donald trump uns geschlagen werden und
ich werde alles in meiner macht stehende
tun damit das gelingt am kommenden
sonntag in der ersten debatte mit nur
zwei kandidaten haben die amerikaner die
möglichkeit zu sehen wer von beiden am
besten geeignet ist dieses ziel zu
erreichen
der linksgerichtete senders macht weiter
gegen den moderaten joe biden
der setzte seine siegesserie fort räumte
vor allem mithilfe afroamerikanischer
wähler in den südstaaten ab und auch im
wichtigsten bundesstaat michigan gewann
er dort hatte vor vier jahren noch
bernie sanders die nase vorn beiden
siegesfeier fiel wegen des corona virus
klein aus doch journalisten
transportierten seine botschaft ins land
gewinnen heißt amerika zu vereinen und
nicht noch mehr teilung und wut zu sehen
es heißt einen präsidenten zu haben der
kämpft aber eben auch heilen kann beiden
präsentiert sich als versöhner als mann
der mitte ein rezept das bei den wählern
funktioniert hat die setzen offenbar
lieber auf altbewährtes als auf eine
politische revolution senders linkes
programm ist vielen zu radikal
wer aber glaubte weiter daran am ende
gegen trump anzutreten
peter jäger aus washington jetzt ein
fall in augsburg der vor mehr als drei
monaten viele menschen aufgewühlt hat
nach einem besuch des weihnachtsmarkts
dort war ein feuerwehrmann tödlich
attackiert wurden jetzt kommen sechs der
sieben tatverdächtigen wieder auf freien
fuß der grund das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat der
beschwerde eines 17-jährigen
mutmaßlichen mittäters stattgegeben der
haftbefehl sei nicht ausreichend
begründet
der mutmaßliche haupttäter sitzt weiter
in untersuchungshaft
im fall des hundertfachen missbrauchs
von kindern in münster hat die
staatsanwaltschaft die verfahren gegen
zehn mitarbeiter von jugendämtern und
polizeidienststellen eingestellt das
ließe sich nicht nachweisen dass die
ermittler hinweise vorsätzlich nicht
weitergegeben und die
behördenmitarbeiter ihre fürsorgepflicht
verletzt hätten
auf einem campingplatz in löste in
ostwestfalen waren über mehrere jahre
kinder missbraucht wurden die beiden
haupttäter sind zu zwölf und 13 jahren
haft mit anschließender
sicherungsverwahrung verurteilt wurden
23 jahre haft das ist die strafe für
harry winston
der frühere hollywood produzent war
wegen vergewaltigung und sexueller
nötigung verurteilt worden
jetzt gab das gericht in new york das
strafmass bekannt
den schuldspruch begrüßte die
staatsanwaltschaft als warnung für alle
sexualstraftäter mainz dienst
verteidigerin nannte das urteil
lächerlich johannes hano berichtet mit
dem gefängnis transporter kommt habe ich
mein steam heute durch den hintereingang
im rollstuhl zur verkündung seines
strafmaßes ins gericht zwischen 5 und 29
jahren gefängnis droht nie unter beifall
einiger zuschauer kamen auch seine opfer
jessica mcnamee haley 23 jahre dann das
urteil des richters das hohe strafmaß
begründete er mit den worten es sei zwar
einst dienst erste verurteilung aber
nicht sein erstes vergehen die
staatsanwaltschaft zufrieden mit der
hohen strafe der richter hat heute eine
botschaft gesendet dass jeder
potenzielle täter sich überlegen sollte
ob er sich so verhält
der richter hat die sache sehr ernst
genommen genauso wie wir das für richtig
halten dafür sind wir danken
[Musik]
erleichterung glücklich auch die opfer
mit einer geste des triumphs tritt deren
anwältin vor die kameras so sieht
gerechtigkeit aus 20 plus drei jahre
sollte das urteil bestand haben käme war
ins team wohl eben nicht mehr aus dem
gefängnis seine anwältin geschockt das
strafmaß
dieses gericht gerade verhängt hat ist
obszön die höhe ist wieder werte jetzt
gibt mörder die schneller wieder
freikommen
das hohe strafmaß folgt dem druck einer
bewegung und der öffentlichen meinung
das ganze verfahren sei unfair gewesen
so donner roth uno aus mangel an
beweisen hätten die geschworenen im
zweifel für den angeklagten entscheiden
müssen
man werde jetzt in berufung gehen und
das ist der moment in der sendung für
christin genau fußball königsklasse
er bleibt sich die zum ersten mal im
viertelfinale der champions league gegen
den letztjährigen final teilnehmer
tottenham hotspur erzählt marcel
sabitzer zwei der drei tore zum
souveränen 13 0 endstand ein fußballfest
noch mit publikum glückliche zuschauer
zukünftig wohl eher ein seltenes bild
dabei haben die leipziger sportlich
durchaus weitere geschichtsträchtige
champions league abende im sinn
wir müssen einfach nur glauben alles ist
möglich nichts ist unmöglich sind alle
menschen und haben heute einen guten tag
gehabt und auch in london einen guten
tag gehabt und wenn eine gute tage haben
können wir jeden schlagen keine
vermessene aussage angesichts der
souveränen vorstellung schon vor der
pause die grundlage zwei treffer für rb
beide durch den überragenden kapitän
marcel sabitzer ein doppelpack so gar
nicht nach dem geschmack von tottenham
trainer mourinho doch sein team bot
wenig leipzig dagegen legte noch einmal
nach e mail forsberg zum 13 entstand vor
einem begeisterten publikum
ja und vor leeren rängen nachher das
achtelfinal-rückspiel im prinzenpark
zwischen paris engagement und borussia
dortmund
außergewöhnliche umstände mit denen alle
zurechtkommen müssen
mit dem vorteil für den bvb das 2 2 1 im
hinspiel verbucht haben
wiedersehen des bvb mit dem ex-trainer
der druck lastet auf thomas tuchel und
seinem aktuellen team von einem
heimvorteil für paris kann keine rede
sein
angesichts leerer ränge im prinzenpark
und die psi geldgeber wollen endlich den
internationalen erfolg der umgang mit
der eigenartigen situation eine
kopfsache
wir müssen nicht wie sagt man überrascht
zahlen oder wir müssen uns auch mental
vorbereiten
ob ihr sie superstar kilian im papi in
der startelf steht ist offen
im training gestern fehlte er der korona
verdacht habe sich als mandelentzündung
entpuppt so französische medien mit
ausnahme von marco reus kann bvb trainer
lucien favre aus dem vollen schöpfen
auch ohne den kapitän ist dortmund sturm
mit erling holland und jayden sancho in
topform
na ja der komplette bundesliga spieltag
wird am wochenende ohne zuschauer
ausgetragen so viel sagte kristin gern
so lust auf lotto klar kein problem
die gewinnzahlen lauten 7 23 24 41 47 49
und die superzahl 5 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im
zdf text auf seite 55 7
das wetter wird stürmisch dazu gibt es
viele schauer schön bleibt es nur an den
alpen alle details gleich von gunther
tiersch von uns war es das danke dass
sie dabei waren mehr hat der kollege
claus kleber im heute journal um 21 uhr
50 bis morgen wenn sie mögen aber
erstmal in allen einen angenehmen haben
[Musik]
liebe zuschauer im norden wird es
stürmisch in der mitte und im süden eher
nass da zieht so ein kleines sturmtief
von großbritannien über die nordsee
richtung dänemark da ist ein wolkenband
dabei das bringt uns den regen zieht
weiter nach süden morgen und es wird da
wird etwas kühler die wärme langsam nach
osteuropa abgedrängt
heute nacht erst mal der kräftige regen
der aufziehende norddeutschland ab
mitternacht gibt es dann auch schwere
sturmböen an der nordseeküste morgen
früh dann auch an der ostseeküste und im
osten sonst im süden bleibt es trocken
und morgen haben wir weiterhin windiges
wetter starker westwind in
mittelgebirgen und im norden der
zuschauer oder dauerregen vielleicht mit
schnee oder graupel in
schleswig-holstein ja anfangs im
vormittag ist es im süden noch
freundlich südlich des mains nachmittags
kann es dann anfang
auch an der donau so langsam zu regnen
während es im norden auflockert und da
wird es ganz freundlich später ein paar
regenschauer münsterland oder im emsland
die temperaturen sind verhalten im
norden und im westen sieben bis zwölf
grad im osten 14 und im süden teilweise
wird's richtig mit bis zu 18 grad ja
freitag wird es kühler es wird windiger
unbeständiger und zum wochenende kommt
die sonne raus und sonntag wird es dann
auch deutlich wärmer ich wünschen noch
einen schönen abend und machen sie's gut